[Musique]
chaque fois que
j'aime tout m'énerve et tout me
surprend pourtant c'est toujours pareil
et
différent chaque fois que
j'aime je découvre un monde fermé où la
raison d'être est
aimé pour
aimer c'est comme un premier soleil qui
me
brûle un premier jour merveilleux de
printemps qui me tire d'un
sommeil
ridicule le cœur
battant comme un enfant
[Musique]
ouais chaque fois que
j'aime tout m'énerve et tout me
surprend pourtant c'est toujours pareil
et
[Musique]
différent chaque fois que
j'aime je découvre un monde
fermé où la raison d'être TR
aimé pour
aimer c'est comme un premier
soleil ça
brûle un premier jour merveilleux de
[Musique]
printemps qui me tire d'un
sommeil
ridicule
le cœur
[Musique]
battant comme un enfant
ouais c'est toujours de même tout
m'énerve et tout me
surprend car à chaque fois que
[Musique]
j'aime chaque fois que
j'aime
j'ai
V
[Musique]
temps bravo